pepper plants are popular at the museo
de siencias natorales
in madrid spain a country famous for
using peppers in cuisine
yet it's their roots rather than their
succulent fruits
that were the subject of new research
conducted at the museum's greenhouse
though a plant's growth above ground is
highly observable
its subterranean development lacks
visibility
this forces scientists to rely on
piecemeal techniques
to measure roots spatial behavior or
growth patterns according to distance
and limited mathematical models to
predict their biomass
the recent research in madrid sought to
reconcile this dilemma
a new mathematical formula incorporated
both space
and biomass to build a more complete
model of root growth
researchers then tested its accuracy
using a novel experiment
first they set up soil-filled
construction gutters inside a greenhouse
in some gutters they arranged pairs of
pepper plants
roughly 10 centimeters apart in others
solitary plants were grown without
neighbors all of the plants were given
equal access to light and water
as well as fertilizer rich with
phosphorus nitrogen
iron and other key nutrients as the
plants grew
scientists injected the plant stems with
red and blue dyes
so that they could distinguish between
the roots of competing plants
finally they piece together root
fragments according to their owners
measuring their density lengths and
positions in the soil beds
plants tend to invest resources closer
to their stems
adding more roots to the soil near their
source as they
spread symmetrically but the experiment
showed paired plants invested even more
resources closer to their stems
than solitary plants they also grew
fewer roots as they neared their
neighbors
where resources became scarcer amid
greater competition
these patterns closely aligned with the
study's model
which predicted that neighboring plant
roots would segregate and change how
they invest resources
in order to acquire as many resources as
possible
by confirming the model the research
helped resolve
contradictory results from previous
experiments
where root biomass sometimes increased
and other times decreased
in the presence of neighboring plants
turns out the closer the plants are to
their neighbors
the more they invest in their roots
overall
their evolutionary programming causes
them to add
more and more roots near their stems
rather than extend across
space to compete for survival the
researchers believe
their findings could help genetically
reprogram plants to maximize crop yields
climate modelers could also make better
projections of earth's vegetation
the significant carbon sink by factoring
in the underground life of plants
oh the places they'll grow
[Music]
you